ciao ragazzi bentornati a una puntata di
cucina buttata oggi è san valentino
volevo fare una ricetta per tutte quante
le coppiette innamorate a base di sull 1
per tutte invece le coppiette in crisi
quindi la maggior parte di quelle che ci
stanno seguendo e per tutte le persone
single
abbiamo deciso di fare una ricetta che
si assiste insieme a qualcuno se si
estende da soli comunque mi porto a casa
felicita cosa più bella da far san
valentino e regalare il proprio cuore a
qualcuno anche a se stessi se si è
particolarmente disperati ma questa
volta lo faremo fritto e filante per la
puntata di oggi di cucina buttata faremo
un cordon bleu enorme a forma di cuore
un cordon perché quello è l'animale
dell'amore per fare il cordone gigante
avremmo bisogno di un filetto molto
spesso di pollo forma giazza prosciutto
crudo salvia polvere di stelle nuova per
l'impanatura olio per friggere
vabbè sarà molto più di questo ragazzo
pangrattato che stiamo andando a
recuperare patate e mio ranocchio ripe
picchio per prima cosa visto che mi
state apprestando a cucinare per
qualcuno qualcuno a qualcuno che
comunque vi spezzerà il cuore affilate
il coltello perché quando si fa un
cattivo investimento bisogna sempre
preparare le armi prendiamo a questo
punto questo enorme petto di pollo
mandiamo a tagliare a metà senza
arrivare alla fine come faccio io in
maniera del tutto improvvisata
ricordatevelo sempre se ci riesco io ci
potete riuscire anche voi precisi in
tensione perché pericoloso è certo che
pericoloso rischio veramente di passare
un intero pomeriggio a fare un qualcosa
per una testa di capra matricolati apuli
la bocca perché liquore se invece mi
puoi ridare il mio fratello per prima
cosa ci tengo a ricordare di rischio di
via questo canale metterci un bel
pollice in su se anche a voi l'amore ha
messo nel culo per seconda cosa ci
tenevo anche a ringraziare jacques club
tv in questa moore bando la ricetta ma
vi lasceremo comunque linke descrizione
qua sotto qualora dovesse andare male in
modo che poteva andare a insultarli sul
loro canale instagram momento di alta
cucina dovremo ora fare delle incisioni
per aprire il cuore come se fosse un
abbraccio dovrà abbracciare dentro lise
il
maggio e prosciutto chiudendola al suo
interno con molta attenzione mi
raccomando ragazzi su e giù primo piano
più veloce vedete si crea un abbraccio
perfetto aspetto questo che va bene
quando vedo bene questo continua
continua continua e mi fermo qui
pazzesco apriamo il nostro cuore e
mettiamoci nostri ingredienti parto con
la forma giazza ma lo sai che
svolgeranno cresci 4 l'accusa ma se uno
della coppia non ama il formaggio si può
sempre mettere lacrime che verserà
quando lo mondo c'è una magagna mercato
per ge combatteva argento enrico siamo a
prosciutto nel frattempo vorrei
chiedervi di iscrivermi qua sotto un
pensiero carino che avete avuto nei
confronti di una persona che poi via
completamente deluso e che avreste
voluto evitarvi completamente fatto io
ero giovanissimo facevo il cameriere il
mio primo stipendio hanno investito
tutto quanto per comprare gli delle
sederemo da tantissimo ma che ce le rose
poi non lasciato perché non riusciamo a
trovare a ci siamo io invece non mi
pento di nulla decreto se stato
fidanzato con una persona io non mi
pento nulla del nulla di un botto fatemi
sapere son curioso a un altro strato di
prosciutto un altro strato di forma
jazzar hammami a certe credo che poi si
battagliato bisogna usare questi per
coprirlo certo non c'è altro pollo
fondamentale prima di chiuderlo andiamo
a condirlo quindi ci mettiamo del sale
pepe salvi up iniziamo trinco sprinkle
dino dal salvia p chiudiamo 12 cui tre
ragazzi temo che avremo bisogno di più
fettine di pollo che andremo a prendere
perché teoricamente loro riescono a
chiuderlo tutto perché è così spesso il
taglio è così fatto bene è ricco
capace bravo l'agorà sei contento spero
che stasera sata riprenda in sonno come
passerà in questo san valentino in
dubbio
speriamo che non vada sono reati
rinforzi abbiamo altre fettine
sottilissime di pollo e poter
raggiungere comunque posso dire cosa te
magni questo mammamia romangia in due in
questo modo una serata diventa picche
alle otto e mezza cosine questa è una
ricetta per le coppie collaudate come
non hanno più passioni non hanno più
nulla da dirsi e duro fino a dormire
andiamo a metterlo in freezer per 1 ora
devo cambiarlo questo per questo il
problema è che è l'uomo di neanderthal
una cicoria ci vedi che non è la prima
volta cerco di non farlo mai
ma quando mi regalate questi sogni e
queste emozioni con queste ricette del
cazzo ventina di minuti e sto creando un
passaggio semola guarda cosa ho rilevato
un guanto entra la perfezione ciao
passato un ora andiamo a vedere che cosa
è successo all'interno del nostro magico
figlio non mi sembra un gelato
sinceramente ri niente queste sono le
cazzate che dicono su internet un'ora il
loro lo hanno tirato fuori che era di
legno ma sa che faremo noi in frigia
munque se viene vale niente e che non
venga affitto qua sotto e non avete
aspettato un'ora perché abbiamo
aspettato
ora faremo facendo cascare la farina
milioni da dire incompetenza di quello
che ti pare mi scivola addosso come ci
vorrà la farina sul pavimento che
esattamente come è scivolato a busta
paga all'interno di un camino acceso
usare come cipria cipria
ma la fidanzatina per culto scriventi
qua sotto se avete un bulldog francese
adatto per culto guarda sano mentre si
troverebbe pure lui suoi standard sono
bassissimi preoccupato come quelli del
tuo padrone ci credo ma mi vedeva no non
so da dove sia uscita sole però centro
io ma che cazzo vuoi da me mettiamo
l'olio in padella vento abbiamo messo
anche il termometro mettendo il timer a
140 gradi che sono il minimo per
friggere le uova as pennello l'uovo
brutto brutto girato perché deve essere
dio quanto parli dice che viene male
grazie al cavolo sei succube di questo
cuore tutti allevato di energie energie
pensa accompagnato con una combo letale
pangrattato sigillum sigillum comunque
per 15 persone altre no non ci credo
link rollando sono disperato ha
sbagliato ragazzi avrei dovuto prima
spennellare e metterci sotto il
pangrattato poi girarlo loris penello
che bello e una foto lato a questo
momento non si perde la calma ogni mossa
ma come fare se come fare prendiamo la
calma sigillo sigillando si è fermato il
casinò sento aver fatto tutto quanto
abbiamo bisogno però di una padella
calda in modo che sigilli al volo le
uscite è quel punto se prega tu ti rendi
conto che un calderone della morte che
cos'è questo sento che non è croccante
come deve diventare commentate
commentate commentate allora giorno per
questa che abbiamo messo qui non è carta
igienica giuro che non lo è anche perché
più che un cuore è un q se la doratura
ce l'ha non ha vomitato fuori formaggio
validi strumenti di cugina solo perché
rotolo se è finito andiamo a tamponare è
carino è un po un cuore marcio ha preso
ispirazione dal mio andiamo all'assaggio
crudo disastro non aumentano in forno
solo fallimenti questa cucina un cuore
spezzato
se volete mantenere intatto il vostro
rapporto da forno per una quarantina di
minuti lo facciamo riscaldare 200 gradi
speriamo che tutto vada bene nella
pellicola sperando che non si stufi e
quindi gli anti motion le possibilità di
disastro sono altissime però devo andare
sul social viola in live quindi mi
prendo una pausa quello che vedrete sarà
tutto catturato da telefoni un san
valentino tra amanti sarà capito una
cosa clan di straordinarie per l'amore è
[Applauso]
[Risate]
lento il profumo è delizioso un profumo
che non se lo merita la persona vista e
sarà il quadro per voi si è fatta notte
bellissimo paiono più piccolo cioè così
è bello
ma più piccolo un grande sacco
nonostante tutto a perdersi con gli
operatori video si sente arrivati a
questo punto complimenti non farmi
leader grazie ci vediamo la prossima
volta che è un giovedì perché porge
domenica borsa maritino a tutte le
coppie decreto un like perché siamo
disperati
il buono va beh scusate